bonjour tyran jose abel tiers au bon
moment et au bon moment bah oui parce
qu'aujourd'hui tu vas nous faire ton
plat favori aujourd'hui c'est vrai on
sait mon plat préféré que je vais faire
c'est à dire aujourd'hui on va faire une
bonne paella
parce que quand on est avec des habits
c'est vrai que d'habitude c'est pas la
cuisine bistrot mais c'est un plan qui
est qui rend une amitié entre nous
formidable à chaque fois comment
chaussée super faire la fiesta pour
faire la fiesta
donc je dis on va faire une paella pour
huit personnes alors les ingrédients il
va lui falloir 4 cuisses de poulets
qu'on coupera en deux 2 poivrons verts 2
poivrons rouges
cinq grosses tomates huit grosses
langoustines
c'est ce bouquet ou crevettes roses
16000 d'espagne est rousse des grosses
500 g de caen-la-mer ou encore nés en
corner ah c'est le même la même chose
deux sorriso ou horizons en herbe et il
ya tous les rôles des drôles de noms
qu'on doit changer on a chacun notre
façon de le dire
4 gousses d'ail 200 g de petits pois
écossés 800 g de riz long quatre gros
oignons du safran de l'huile d'olive à
peu près a décidé une botte de persil
sont pour la fin on supposera de persil
haché du sel du poivre
on a tout pour faire notre feuille et un
plat et à plainfaing et là ça c'est un
plat paella le vrai à peu bosselé ya
déjà souffert mais c'est le rep la
paella dans fois un peu large pour
commencer notre baiia faut d'abord faire
revenir le poulet dans l'huile d'olive
alors à peu près un décilitre et c'est
parti il faut bien recouvrir d'olive
on va faire chauffer et quand ce sera
bien chaud on va faire colorer et puis
notre poule et il va d'abord cuire
pendant un quart d'heure vingt minutes
dans un indice d'olive voilà une ça sent
déjà bon
on n'est pas que celle ci dessous non
alors j'ai pris quatre cuisse de poulet
que j'ai coupé en deux donc ça fait mon
poulet pour une personne on va alors que
les retourner ça commence à colorer
elles sont dit adorer ça saute un peu
viagra du poulet et j'ai mis un peu
d'huile d'olive un peu plus parce
qu'après ça va absorber sous les légumes
et on va laisser colorer et cuire
pendant 10 minutes un quart d'heure pour
dire que la toux les cuisses est ce
qu'on va faire maintenant qu'on l'a
retourné fission vassal et voilà pendant
que mon poulet cuit on va commencer à
préparer
toi tu veux finir des poivrons et on va
rajouter d'abord les oignons on va
d'abord prendre des produits qui frise
un peu plus longtemps alors les oignons
achille et massez grossièrement on va
ajouter les oignons et faire colorer
tout doucement les oignons et quand
c'est coloré on ajoutera le poivron est
maintenant sûr on va rajouter poivrons
les poivrons et verts et les rouges les
verts et les rouges
cette couleur bien voilà et maintenant
tu vas ajouté le calamar houle en corner
que j'ai aimé c'est parce que ça
paraisse aqmi un peu plus longtemps
alors pareil
et mme assez grossièrement parce que il
va rétrécir pas mal en faisant alors le
corps iso j'ai oublié d'expliquer c'est
du corps izod ou la salade du genou ou
alors vous mais parce que si on prend
lui trop pimenté ça devient intenable
sur la panne
je vais rajouter mais 4 gousses d'ail
alors pareils à sion hacher
grossièrement emma c'est parce que comme
ça vacui après avec le riz pendant 25
minutes
il faut vraiment content on reconnaisse
le goût et les deux latéraux
voilà maintenant tu peux maintenant
sorriso voilà parcimonie en aura pour
tout le monde sait pas compter ils
partageront
88 alors quatre cinq minutes ça va cuire
le plus gros est fait maintenant alors
c'est là je te disais la paella quand
cela s'est fait il restera plus qu'à
s'occuper du riz moi c'est ça mon petit
truc je vais mettre mon riz à cuire
commencé dans une casserole lyon vers
salle rit dessus waller et les tomates
et il ya mes tomates un hébergement que
celle à isabelle donc on met les tomates
mais les tomates foulée m au dernier
moment parce que tom sa cuite très vite
sinon ça devient tout de suite de l'eau
voilà
[Musique]
or mais lens ça sert quand même d'un
petit femmes à la maison maintenant tout
est en train de se confier je vais me
retirer pour mon lit je prends une
casserole
je mets un petit peu d'huile d'olive et
on va faire blondir l'oignon haché à
demi oignon haché
j'avais commencé on va finir on va le
faire blondir légèrement cet homme henri
pinault comme un riz pilaf un petit peu
et je vais m regarde une belle dose 1100
grammes de riz et on va mettre deux fois
et demi la dose d'eau alors c'est le
moment avant de mettre mon dos je vais
ajouter mon safran a le safran alors
voilà c'est du safran et voilà on va
mettre à peu près l'équivalent d'une
petite cuillère à café
voilà la sable on dit un peu savant dit
et je met mon no 2 me c'est ça ouais de
nos ennemis
oui
voilà
mais non alors de deux ennemis mon
permettent de donne aussi là je vais en
met deux si des fois on en met un peu
trop bas france évaporer l'eau est pas
bien rajouter un petit peu de sel pour
saler son oui voilà isabelle regarde
morilles et presque cuit mais donc il ya
dix douze minutes de cuisson sa famille
de couverte pas le trouver à qu'on n'est
pas obligé de mettre à couvert puis
comme ça on le surveille un petit peu là
une belle couleur et on va donc
reprendre le travail là confidentiel est
belle alors le voilà les biens confie
donc on va poser les petits pois encore
pour colorer
ça y est c'est un bout du genre je vais
poser mais langoustines aimé bouquet
alors une langoustine par personne donc
on va embêter fuite
elles sont belles alors rousse tu peux
poser des bouquets 2 par personne alors
tu le mets comme cela entre deux pas se
mettre à couvert de riz voilà on va
cuire langoustines je soupe ou jacques
maury bien il faut quand même que le riz
soit sécurisé info à ce que je vais
faire comme la leur et robert peugeot je
vais rajouter un petit peu d'eau tout
simplement dans la casserole
donc tout à l'heure j'ai mis deux
volumes d'eau maman bien kilomètres de
volume et demi on les épluche sera dans
l'assiette évoqué un petit peu de points
je vais remettre le reste de petits pois
donc ce soit bien vert et comme on n'a
pas de fous on va mettre un petit papier
d'aluminium pour le cuire pendant
pourquoi langoustines cuisent et dans
cinq six minutes là on le voit en mettra
nos boules
voilà isabelle et langoustines commence
à cuire
je vais remuer mapa et l'homme n'en ai
regardé couleurs et c'est maintenant
voilà c'est maintenant qu'on va mettre
nos moules alors ça paraît compliqué
mais c'est vraiment un plaisir à faire
c'est le genre de plan qui va tout seul
à faire on les plans et ce sera la
dernière partie on trouve le sort isolé
tomates les poivrons
allez-vous le trouvère clac clac c'est
presse et l'appel
voilà alors doucement mal formé en
vacances c'est vrai que la paella c'est
les vacances et maintenant on va la
laisser cuire 5 minutes
d'autres poids lourds y prêtent les
moules sont ouverts je vais c'est quand
même quelque chose d'intimé soupoudrée
de persil haché reste encore de la
couleur sur son impact trop quand même
voilà est valable à ma petite file à la
voile à l île est terminée elle va être
on va aller déguster ça va le faire qu
est retombé pardon elle regarde tous
avoir d'abord mademoiselle la
langoustine tu vois le poulet le calamar
le sorriso il ya déjà de quoi faire on
pour toi à la même chose boostés et une
tête maul le poulet le poulet on va pas
toujours dit la même chose mais vraiment
il faut être heureux un composé avec sa
[Musique]
belle goûtez moi ça avec plaisir